en el vídeo pasado vimos cómo gastar 50
pesos en donde nuestras opciones eran
chocolates que cada uno la barra se
vendía en 10 pesos o bien fruta donde
cada kilo de fruta costaba 20 pesos
teníamos unas ciertas tablas de utilidad
marginal que nos decían que tanta
utilidad o teníamos por comprar
chocolates adicionales o kilos
adicionales entonces lo que hicimos
después fue calcular la utilidad
marginal por precio y con eso ya
podíamos ver que nos convenía así
digamos una forma racional de gastar el
dinero era maximizando la utilidad
marginal por precio y entonces el primer
chocolate nos convenía más que el primer
kilo de fruta el segundo chocolate
también el tercer chocolate nos daba lo
mismo pero podríamos pensar que también
y ya después de comprar estos tres
chocolates ya no nos convenía comprar
chocolates porque teníamos una utilidad
marginal por precio menor que la de la
fruta así acabamos comprando tres
chocolates y dos barras de fruta y con
eso maximiza vamos la utilidad que
obteníamos lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es generalizar este concepto y
pensarlo en una versión un poco más
continua a qué me refiero con esto pues
básicamente a que ahora se van a poder
pues cualquier cantidad de barras por
chiquitas que sean fracciones de barras
super super chiquitas y también
fracciones de kilos bueno voy a pasar
aquí abajo para hacer esto y entonces
vamos a realizar una gráfica vamos a
graficar algo con dos ejes aquí tenemos
un eje vertical un eje horizontal en el
eje vertical vamos a poner la utilidad
marginal por presión que va a estar
medida en ciertas unidades digamos que
aquí es 5 y que aquí es 10 recuerda que
son unidades abstractas no son pesos ni
bienes son unidades de utilidad y de
este lado vamos a poner pesos gastados
aquí es pesos gastados
y vamos a pensar que podemos gastar 10
o veinte o treinta y cuarenta cincuenta
pesos bueno sobre esta gráfica voy a
dibujar la utilidad marginal por precio
de dos bienes muy bien
y un bien ve entonces supongamos que la
utilidad marginal del bien se ve algo
más o menos de este estilo baja
acuérdate que la utilidad marginal baja
mientras más gastes verdad porque si
tienes más objetos de algo ya no te
sirven tanto como al principio
y supongamos que la utilidad marginal de
bsb más o menos bueno esta década deja
le pongo es la utilidad marginal de a
por cada precio d
y supongamos que la bebé se ve más o
menos así entonces este es otro bien que
al principio no lo prefieres tanto y que
luego baja y más o menos cruza digamos
por acá más o menos algo de este estilo
va entonces está en azul en azul claro
es la utilidad marginal de ve
por precio debe muy bien entonces vamos
a pensar cómo gastar cierto dinero no
vamos a pensar que no tenemos ningún
límite de dinero va que tenemos todo lo
que queremos para gastar entonces
ahorita como todo es muy continuo
podemos incluso gastar en centavos más
entonces vamos a pensar en nuestro
primer centavo donde sería bueno gastar
ese primer centavo lo voy a poner así
con color naranja entonces ahí tenemos
un primer centavo pues donde lo vamos a
gastar pues en verdad quién nos da una
mucho mayor
y utilidad marginal por precio que ve
entonces nuestro primer centavo lo vamos
a gastar así luego el segundo centavo
también aquí también y también y también
entonces incluso qué sucede con nuestros
primeros 10 pesos todos esos 10 pesos
nos convienen más gastar los a ver
déjame borrarlo así para que quede
derechito nos conviene más gastarlos en
a porque nos dan una mayor utilidad
marginal por precio que ve y de hecho si
quisiéramos obtener la utilidad total de
lo que obtenemos pagando esos 10 pesos
tendríamos que calcular el área de esta
región de por acá
vale no es simplemente 10 por 10 porque
10 por 10 sería el área de este
rectángulo que viene como por acá arriba
que es más de lo que queremos en
realidad sólo queremos el área debajo de
la curva y bueno cuando llegues cálculo
o si ya lo llevaste podrás obtener una
mejor intuición de cómo se comporta esto
de las áreas debajo de las curvas vale
pues nosotros son los primeros 10 pesos
pero luego qué sucede con los siguientes
10 pesos pues esos siguientes 10 pesos
también nos conviene gastar los en la
verdad tenemos una utilidad marginal más
alta entonces vamos por acá tenemos esta
utilidad marginal
pero ahora qué sucede entonces ya
llegamos hasta aquí verdad pero qué
sucede con el siguiente centavo mira el
siguiente centavo es más o menos algo de
por aquí si lo gastamos en nada pero
también si lo gastamos en ve como apenas
estamos empezando a gastar en vez
entonces tenemos una utilidad marginal
similar entonces aquí nos da básicamente
lo mismo gastar en nada o gastar en vez
aquí o aquí bueno qué sucede con el
siguiente centavo vamos a pensar que el
primero bueno que este de aquí lo
gastamos en vez entonces podemos
gastarlo en vez
y luego otra vez en be pero qué sucede
si empezamos a gastar demasiado en be
pues como ya gastamos mucho en be ahora
nos va a haber convenido más entonces
ahora vamos a tener que haber gastado en
a entonces qué es lo que sucede sea más
bien como que lo que sucede es que si
empezamos a gastar mucho lo suficiente
como para pasar este punto en el cual
nos conviene a entonces a partir de ese
momento ya tenemos que empezar a dividir
nuestro gasto entre a y b porque si de
repente empezamos a estar mucho en nada
más bien había algunas unidades bebé que
todavía nos convenía comprar y de modo
similar si empezamos a gastar mucho en
be entonces había unidades de a que nos
conviene que éste pues gastar más en
ellas entonces esto está súper padre
este es un fenómeno muy muy interesante
lo que dice es que comprando lo
suficiente en este caso 20 pesos
la utilidad marginal por precio debe es
igual a la utilidad marginal por precio
de a son equivalentes en cierto sentido
por ejemplo si hay fruta y ves xocolate
entonces lo que nos dice esto es que en
la última fracción así en el último
gasto una vez que pasamos este umbral de
acá pues vamos a pensar qué es
bueno al menos en términos de utilidad
marginal por precio que es lo mismo
comprar el último cachito de kilo de
fruta que comprar así el último gramo de
chocolate entonces se empiezan a ver
iguales a nuestro parecer entonces
déjame escribirlo de este lado tenemos
que en esta situación una vez que
pasamos ese umbral tenemos que la
utilidad marginal debe
por precio bebé es equivalente a la
utilidad marginal de a por precio de
aquí fruta de chocolate vale ojo aquí no
estoy diciendo que sean iguales estas
dos porque en realidad decir igual que
son iguales es decir como algo un poco
más complicado tampoco estoy diciendo
que hay un bien que sea mejor que el
otro lo único que está diciendo esta
igualdad es lo siguiente que hay un
cierto umbral que cuando lo pasamos
cuando lo atravesamos es decir al gastar
lo suficiente te va a dar exactamente lo
mismo comprar este oeste y entonces por
lo tanto debes de empezar a comprar
cantidades iguales para obtener o bueno
para maximizar tu utilidad marginal va
porque una vez más si compráramos mucho
de a después de este umbral si
compráramos mucha fruta entonces ahora
el chocolate es que no estamos
aprovechando que nos dando una mayor
utilidad y de modo similar si compramos
mucho mucho chocolate entonces ahora
tenemos una cierta cantidad de fruta que
nos da más utilidad que el chocolate
adicional